foreign
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored with
me Richard Tice and me Isabella shot
quasi-quartang held the nation's first
string as the British economy imploded
his friend and Ally Liz just fired him
to save her own job which she lost
anyway just six days later tonight in
his first live interview since the 44
days that changed political history
quasi-guarteng joins us in the studio
plus almost 2 million British people use
illicit Black Market cannabis to manage
their medical conditions is it time to
relax the law and possibly even tax it
we'll debate that as well
live from London this is here's Morgan
uncensored with Richard Tice and
Isabelle Oak shots
well he was a man who had it all blessed
with a brilliant brain he was a king
scholar at Eaton got a double first at
Cambridge he was a Kennedy scholar at
Harvard and then he added a PhD to his
name his first taste of the Limelight
light was way back in 1995 when he was a
member of the team that won the BBC quiz
show University challenge after a stint
in the city he landed one of the safest
seats in the country becoming a
conservative MP in 2010 he then worked
his way up to the second most powerful
political position in the country as
Britain's first black Chancellor
quasi-quarting is one of those annoying
people that are good at almost
everything except perhaps looking after
our cash because within 38 days of his
appointment to the treasury it was all
over his first budget had blown up and
his close friends and political Ally Liz
truss had thrown him to the wolves in a
vain attempt to save her own skin and in
the the ultimate humiliation he actually
learned he was about to be fired when he
read it on Twitter well reeling from one
of the most shocking political betrayals
in modern history and amid accusations
he'd crashed the economy quasi quite
understandably went to ground now he's
finally ready to talk live about how his
career went up in smoke along with his
vision for the UK economy
well the former Chancellor quasi-coating
joins us now hello thanks for being with
us you blew that pretty badly didn't you
quasi well it was a turbulent time I
mean we can laugh about it but we'll try
to do a serious thing we try to reduce
the tax burden on this country and we
were caught in a in a real Firestorm and
I think
um it's a shame what happened I do
regret some of the things that we did in
terms of the speed but I think the
general direction in terms of lowering
taxes right well look before we get on
to all that I I want to just step back a
minute I mean this is your first live
interview since you left office you're
kind of off the leash aren't you I mean
previously you've always had to watch
what you say because you were in cabinet
for a very long time for quite a long
time I mean I was and there was a
minister or PPS the chancellor which is
you know very uh it's taken Adventure
but you're kind of on them but you still
have to watch what yeah you're part of
what they call the paper so I hope
you're not going to hold back um well
I'm going to speak uh as as freely as I
can but but what I would say is that I
was in those jobs as a PPS whatever for
about seven years yes
um and now this is the first time really
since 2015 I think probably 2014 that
I've had a live interview as as a
backbencher well look um before we move
on to All Things economic which I Know
Rich is absolutely itching to get into
let's talk for a minute about Nicholas
sturgeon
um you know this is the big story of the
world absolutely
um what do you make of her sudden
resignation I think it's been
fascinating uh I mean I just found out
about it again on Twitter
um and it was very sudden I mean she
said oh she'd been thinking about it a
lot but really the straw that broke the
camels back as you'll remember was the I
think he was called Adam Graham when he
was a man and then he had surgery and
and was called either Bryson and this
man had been convicted of rape twice and
then was put into a woman's uh prison
which defies all common sense and I
think Nicola trying to to say that this
was the right thing to do and she got
herself into lots of knots was really
really the straw to bring the camels
back her ratings are plunged and
essentially her woke agenda ended up
blowing up in her face
I mean she got herself into a hell of a
model as you say
um I don't know whether you remember the
clip of her getting into a real twist
over the definition of a woman and you
know whether a trans woman is a woman
what is a woman as far as you're
concerned well a woman is somebody like
my mother who gave who gives birth or
can has the capacity to give birth to
children
the question that she got into a pickle
over is are trans women women well that
was that was a great I mean I don't
think biologically they are I think you
can call them what you will but
biologically they clearly not
um it's really how so many senior
politicians are getting in such a pickle
I mean it's it's pretty obvious it's
pretty basic stuff isn't it it is but I
think the work agenda has just taken
over and for nicely I mean she's a very
able politician I mean to her credit
she's lasted eight years which is a lot
longer than certainly I was Chancellor
but but but but actually she got herself
into a terrible pickle on uh these quite
basic issues and I think the work agenda
essentially just just I mean but the
truth is and you talk about the worker
gender as if it exists sort of has a
life of its own but the truth is that
the work agenda is pretty Rife
throughout all our institutions now I
mean take the NHS for example
um do you think your own party may
possibly have been a bit too timid on on
these issues no I think if you speak to
people like uh Kimmy badnov or Michael
Gove uh they've been pretty clear about
about you know fundamentals on this and
I think it's very easy for people
politicians to get completely muddled
and defy common sense and I think if you
speak to people like Kenny budnok other
in the conservative party there is very
much a common sense approach to a lot of
these questions okay just just let's
move on because there's been recently
some pretty awful apparently racially
aggravated attacks including one I
believe alleged in your own constituency
um that's obviously going to fuel claims
that Britain is a racist Society what's
your take on so my view broadly is that
Britain I mean you look at any country
in the world Britain is a pretty
tolerant place I mean you look at you
know the fact the prime minister is from
an ethnic background I was in cabinets
with lots of colleagues who are from
ethnic backgrounds that's that's a huge
deal that doesn't mean that there is no
racism in Britain I mean that's do you
feel that you've ever in your whole life
have you ever encountered I can tell you
growing up in the 80s in London was was
much more racially aggravated much there
was much more tension than there is
today I mean you regularly get abuse on
the tube right frequently there was open
uh hostility to ethnic minorities in a
way that you don't see very much today
now I'm not saying it's a perfect world
that we of it in terms of racial Harmony
there are still outstanding issues but I
think Britain has come a very long way
in the 40 years that I've I can remember
I mean in The Firestorm after your um
resignation or firing however we're
going to call it
um you know all sorts of stuff was being
held at you yeah was there any racially
motivated I didn't really
um get involved in that I mean I'm not a
Twitter Warrior I deliberately avoid
getting down those uh rabbit holes
because you can get into all sorts of
fights you know some of my colleagues
are tweeting all the time yeah and
they're in these kind of crazy battles
so I avoided that
um and I wasn't really plugged into a
lot of that did you go into hiding
somewhat no well when you're getting
doorsteps yeah as I was Yeah by media I
I just um fled
um
but I I I I because I knew what would
happen I knew that they would and every
day there were people but after about
four or five days the story moved on so
when I came back
they came back to my house there was
nobody there it was about six days later
the truth was though Liz truss made a
catastrophic mistake firing you I mean
you were in it together and you had to
survive it together yeah and I think I
think we've got a clip here of her
trying to sort of defend that decision
yeah let's let's just look at that
you know I'm
I'm
I can't I can't say it was anything but
extremely difficult but
he was in Washington at the time at the
um IMF meeting
and you know I was getting some very
serious warnings from senior officials
that the you know there could be a
potential Market meltdown
the following week
if I didn't take action and
I needed to do as much as I could
to indicate that things were different
I mean I was looking at your expression
um you looked pretty pissed off I have
to well look you know the fact was she
had a very successful leadership
Campaign which was all about not putting
up tax and I was very clear and I said
it repeatedly that we were going to be
joined at the hip and that was what I
was there to do and so I was in
Washington as you as as she mentioned
and I was summoned back I should have
stayed an extra day but my thinking was
well this is just gonna add you know
create more drama should you have gone
at all because actually so it was wrong
there was they were sort of there was
there was conspiratorial activity going
on behind you back but it was one of
those things if I hadn't gone it would
have been a mass
it was six of one half a dozen of the
other you were damned if you did you
were damned if you didn't if I hadn't
gone it would have been the first time
since God knows when that a British
Chancellor hadn't gone to the annual
meeting yeah in the IMF and that would
have been the story so she so so that
that you know it was it was a difficult
call she said she had no option I'm
quoting here she had no option but to
sack you do you agree well of course I I
don't agree I mean I I think we could
have
um we should have actually worked
together but you know I'm not you should
have toughed it out do you think well I
mean tough it out I think I think the
one thing that I would say is that in
any political there's a general point in
any difficulty in any um you know a
strong stressful uh situation where
people are buffeting you know lots of
people busting around the one thing you
have to do is you know you've got to I
think keep have a very calm approach but
leadership that was what that was what I
wanted to do
um and I thought summoning me back a day
before the everyone could see I mean it
was my blame was being tracked you know
by thousands of people
um and and it just Shone a huge light on
the fact that there was this turmoil but
you know these are finally judged
slightly balanced questions and the
Prime Minister you know was was was
advised she took a difficult decision
she said it to me it was a difficult
decision but at that point when I was
sacked I knew that there wouldn't be
much longer of a Premiership and
actually I think I was it was reported I
didn't see the things that she panicked
well look I mean I don't want to don't
be friends would that be fair but I I
mean if the if the if the argument was
I'm gonna sack my Chancellor so that I
can prolong my political life I don't
think six days uh it was a sign of
massive success in that do you feel let
down by your officials uh possibly by
the sacking of Tom scholar and indeed
let down by the bank of England if
they'd acted differently on that Monday
morning if they'd started buying some
bombs things could have been very very
difficult well they've been committed to
that I think the whole um I think Tom
skola I've said I said it publicly at
the time it's been was an excellent
civil servant but he'd been there 30
years but you fired it and we yeah I
know you know but he wasn't he got a
Knighthood that it was the The Press
said oh this is a total
um you know it shows that they got it
wrong but he'd had 30 years
um and we felt that it was time for him
what about the bank of England I think
the governor of the bank had gone on
quite well uh with him in the short time
I was uh working with him people had
said that um they had you know interest
rates hadn't gone up uh quickly enough
there was there was a lot of chatter
around that but I had a good working
relationship with the governor well what
was quite extraordinary is that having
sacked you uh Liz truss then chose
Jeremy Hunt as your replacement now
she's not close to Jeremy Hunt so where
did that idea come from well I I don't
know you'd have to ask the Prime
Minister but I think it was it's quite
odd that in her essay she's been uh
talking about the uh you know the fact
that the treasury did this and did that
but she appointed Jeremy hunts I mean
that was do you think someone do you
think someone else I don't think so I
think she she had why did she do it then
um because she wanted to stabilize the
markets I think they had uh I think
Jeremy did a good job in that and it's
very much now you know let's try and
stabilize things and not and not uh get
too excitable not try and agitate how
would you characterize Hunt's ideology I
think I think it's a very Orthodox
um treasury
ideology I mean it's pretty boring and
not gonna I mean look it's not it's all
about being boring or being exciting
it's about an approach to economic
management yeah and I think what he's
doing is is trying to stabilize the
market that's what he's been brought in
to do by Liz truss absolutely impacted
him it wasn't Rishi yeah okay well next
tonight the gloves are off we'll be
talking brexit we'll be talking net zero
with the former Chancellor quasi cuarte
don't go anywhere
foreign
[Music]
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
watch with shock Paris how much money
are you worth not as much as you sadly
you're being a Karen they'll all be
spreading the news the big mouth takes
another bite of the Big Apple now the
city that never sleeps is really going
to wake up expect exclusives expect
fireworks and expect the unexpected
all new Piers Morgan uncensored live
from New York City
[Music]
welcome back well the former Chancellor
quasi quateng is still with us and it's
time to talk budget before brexit yeah
well yeah before we get on to brexit the
budget's looming now um fortunately for
you you're not in charge
um but clearly something has to be done
about the tax burden doesn't it it's way
too high well look I mean that was the
whole premise of the leadership contest
that we had in the summer which Liz won
but of course you know what happened in
in October or September happened and now
we've got a new prime minister and a new
Chancellor in their job and I think
they're doing a good job at it actually
is to try and stabilize uh the markets
which they have done I think that's been
successful and they've always said that
they want to reduce taxes when it's
appropriate to do so yeah the question
is when when is that well the reality is
we've got companies like AstraZeneca
Britain's biggest publicly listed
company announcing this week that
they're set setting up a new base in
Dublin you know citing tax Reasons by
the way because corporation tax is so
much lower there how do you see the
implications of that look so I think
that we had uh will there be more that
do that I don't know I don't know I mean
I think I mean I've always been very
clear about the fact that I don't think
High tax you get to Prosperity by um
high taxes I don't think that's the
route to do it some people risk that a
growing number of wealth creators are
just going to leave there's always a
risk when you put taxes up there's
always a risk that people who generate
wealth
um decide to do up sticks and go
somewhere else and that's what Pascal
sorio the head of AstraZeneca who I know
um and I used to speak to when I was a
business secretary
um he made that he made that very clear
in his statement and how do you feel
about that I think it's regrettable I
think they're a great company and I hope
they would come back and maybe
reconsider their decision
but I mean brexit come on you're a
brexiteer you saw it as a a great
opportunity and for three years you were
first administer of State in the
Department of Business and then you
became Secretary of State and as a
Secretary of State for business in a
brexit government I mean the whole thing
was take control of our money our laws
and our borders yeah you had a great
opportunity to start to cut back on the
mountain of Daft bureaucratic EU laws
and you did nothing about no we didn't
we started on that I mean though Jacob
was brought in Jacob Reese Moore was
brought in as a minister in the cabinet
office we looked at regulation we've got
a bill that's coming through which is
going to get rid of a lot of the the EU
regulation but in reality come on you
know that Bill's not going to go through
no I think it has a chance
I never prejudge legislation but that's
clearly the statement of the intent of
the government but this yes but the
establishment is trying to delay it now
by three or four years to 2026. you know
we left in nine at the end of 19. the
end of the transition period was the end
of 20 that's right we brexiteers we said
to the country we deregulate we'd go for
growth we'd cut taxes with controller
borders yeah you had a major opportunity
to cut the regulation and you really had
to start we did start I mean the thing I
would say about the whole EU debate a
bit of perspective we were in this thing
we're in the EU for nearly 50 years
certainly before I was born okay and I
think that a lot of it won't take 50
years to get the benefits it shouldn't
do but having been this we're out of
pressure now having been in it for 50
years I think it was a lot to expect
that immediately we left suddenly
everything would be uh hunky-dory that
wasn't realistic and the other thing
that people have forgotten about and you
you mentioned my whatever departments I
was in I was also in the brexit
department for about nine months so even
more obviously you didn't take advantage
yeah but at that time Richard you'll
remember in 2017 we didn't have a
majority I mean it was a completely
confused situation in terms of where the
party I I accepted in 2017. between 2017
and 19. so for three years essentially
but between we were in gridlock and then
Boris actually managed to to liberate
the uh the grid a lot then kovid came
three months later you weren't involved
with covert you should have been
preparing all of this stuff to just
slash and burn these dark regulations
and you didn't we had a legislation we
had we had we have legislation in place
I worked on that Jacob has worked on
that and it's going through the house of
the parliament well rather than raking
over what's now ancient history what
about where we are now do you think I
mean we've got Jeremy Hahn in the in
number 11
um he was a remainer and Richie sunak
was a brexite I don't know whether he's
a convincing one uh you've heard about
the ditchley park Gathering I mean I've
been to those Gatherings you sadly
weren't invited
you know
um I mean do you is there a danger that
there is a move to slide us back into
the EU I think there is a risk of that
absolutely
absolutely but I mean you heard I think
Michael Hazeltine say this earlier um on
your show he just says well oh the brick
Studios have messed it up then let's go
back into the EU and of course they're
not stupid they're not going to say oh
let's rejoin the EU but they'll Dress It
Up in some form of of Words which
essentially means it will be in the US
of your own on worse terms I don't know
I think the party is committed I know
the Prime Minister uh Rishi is committed
what about Jeremy delivering brexit well
the Prime Minister I mean he's running
the government so he's the one it's one
thing having left yeah but you've got to
take advantage of the opportunities and
two years later after the end of the
transition period yeah you've got
nothing as a government as a
conservative party to show for I think
we've got quite a lot to show for
elections like if you look if you look
at the the big debate in the you'll
remember this because we were on the
same side was the amount we were putting
into the EU okay that was 10 billion in
the old budget uh framework it was 10
billion a year it would have been more
in the 20 in the new budget framework
that's so if you think that's nearly six
years of where we would be paying 10
billion a year that's a lot of money
so on borders at least we've got an
immigration policy
doesn't count for anything no one cares
about a policy quasi we want to control
the policy does matter because what was
happening before is we were having 150
000 people coming into the country that
we had no control over whatsoever have
you got any control over the migrant
boots I think we are trying to get uh
more of a grip on that but we have a
little grip on it at the moment but in
terms of immigration Isabel we have a
lot more say we've got a lot more uh
control of what our policies
the current Home Secretary admitted that
you had lost control of the borders
she's she's she admitted that to I
believe a select committee I didn't see
last year to June 2022 and the year was
the highest ever uh lawful immigration
so essentially you sold to the nation as
a government you've sold a pup you said
brexit was all about controlling our
borders and we've got record levels of
lawful immigration and we've got record
levels of unlawful so brexit as I
remember was not about Banning it all
immigration
record levels no but you know for the
knee and I'm someone who I think we
should be able to attract the best time
absolutely agree into the country I
don't see any problem with that and in
many instances people still want to come
here which is a good thing is that
talent coming over on boots no I mean
they've got to do it legally okay it's
got to be legal it can't be trafficking
it can't be because I feel any of that
kind of Defending Your government's
record and remember you are a bencher
now so you can you can speak so I I am
but I'm also a team player I mean I find
it very frustrating how do you honestly
feel about the never-ending numbers
coming over illegally on but how do you
really frustrated it's extremely
frustrating and also well I'm not
embarrassed we should be I'm I'm I'm
focused I'm trying to come up with
Solutions and the other thing that I
would stress is that you know there are
too many people who you know having been
ministers go on the back benches and
then just freely slag off the government
and don't give the measure of support
when they were as they expected back
benches to support them well so they
should be supporting us backbenchers for
government talking of support obviously
one of the things that you're involved
was was the price of energy the cost of
energy which was going through the roof
yeah and essentially the cost of energy
is it's the other side of the net zero
coin yeah that is the reality and we've
now got a situation where the
government's subsidizing People's Energy
bills and we've got businesses we talked
touched on AstraZeneca the other massive
problem for businesses is the cost of
energy yeah the car industry is
collapsing Ford just yesterday announced
1300 layoffs as they move towards
electrification yeah there are three
thousand across Europe
jlr are moving production overseas
mainly because of the cost of energy and
to do with Net Zero the steel industry
is begging for hundreds of millions of
handouts because of the cost of energy
because of Net Zero many other firms
particularly Hospitality pubs
restaurants their energy bills are going
through the roof they're shutting when
they get off their existing tariffs this
is all because of Net Zero it's all
because of Net Zero
right is directly linked to the move
towards Renewables we're subsidizing 11
billion to Offshore offshore wind farms
it's not a 5 billion of balancing costs
that people have to pay for and the
truth is net zero is making us poorer
it's making us colder
and you're responsible no look I totally
disagree with you the idea that Nets it
just burning more coal and and burning
fossil fuels is that is the future I
think is wrong it's false if you look at
the costs of energy what was driving it
in the in the winter of 2021 was the
fact that China essentially came out of
covid restrictions and there was huge
demand coming out of China for gas and
that pushed the price up and the second
double whammy we had was of course
Putin's Invasion we had nothing to do
sitting on nothing is worth of our own
energy treasure
look it's not just fracking we've got
we've got onshore gas we've got onshore
we've got all these things we're not
we're not exploiting did you see the
profits of centrica today yes that's the
law of that's from from British
yeah but that's what that's what they're
doing we've got all this Shale gas yeah
you know you and Liz briefly uh wanted
to sort of I was never a big fracker
because I realized but it's like there
was a big political problem you say that
the cost of energy is nothing you can do
about it in America the cost of their
energy their gas is a quarter of ours
why because they're fracking because
they're using their own domestic energy
they'll give you a self-reliant on it
and and you as a government to bottled
it so look in Wyoming there were two
people per square kilometer okay in
Lancashire where there was uh some
preliminary fracking uh undertaken it's
about 450 people okay so your ability to
get through any political pressures by
Frankie in Wyoming is far greater than
is the case in England so final question
final question is there a risk The Net
Zero agenda has gone too far I think the
Net Zero agenda is absolutely the right
agenda you're going to say that are you
really I think it's yeah absolutely you
are destroying this not true it's
economy you are making people the idea
that you can burn coal like we did in
the 50s forever and ever thank you so
much completely absurd thank you so much
for joining us it's gone way too quick
we have to have you back on again thank
you positing next tonight we will get
reaction from tonight's Stellar panel
and including Alison Pearson on the
Dominic ra bullying accusations lucky we
didn't ask you about that
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no with the people's Channel nobody use
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back we're joining us in the
studio now our talk TV contributor Paula
Road and Adrian and for the first time
on Piers Morgan uncensored Daily
Telegraph columnist best-selling author
Alison Pearson where you've been
listening to the interview there with
the former Chancellor the first time he
gave a live extended interview I'll come
to you Alison first you're a brexiteer
um how do you feel he he dealt with the
the criticisms he was being very
diplomatic wasn't he he was praising the
present government uh quite a lot I'm
going to put my cards on the table rich
and Isabel I would rather quasi quateng
was still the chance the exchecker than
Jeremy Hunt Jeremy Hunt who when he was
campaigning for the Tory leadership said
he was going to cut corporation tax to
15 he's now going to raise it from 19 to
25 I think that uh quasi-quarting and
Liz truss were on the right lines they
just decided to do everything on the
same day and that backfired politically
I think economically they were much more
sound than what's going on at the moment
I mean interestingly he really did
emphatically fail to endorse Jeremy Hunt
as someone with whom brexit can be
trusted didn't he he kept coming back
well I think the Prime Minister
definitely agrees with brexit so I
sensed that you know he he was being
quite guarded on some of this because I
think ultimately quasi is a team player
and that is why you know he's firing by
his one of his oldest political friends
were so shocking because he'd always
said privately that he would never ever
Stitch her up and then he did that and
he's beginning Paula to talk a little
bit more openly about how that felt
isn't he he is and it's good to hear
however what I'd hoped to hear today was
first of all a very clear apology oh I
knew you were going to say that
and thousands of people who are now
facing the possibility of losing their
homes if not an increase in their
mortgage rates and mortgage repayments
of up to 500 I'm sure that's ridiculous
I'm not sure that that was actually
quasi-parten's fault I mean Richard you
you know you're better on these issues
the reality was is that inflation was
going up so interest rates had to go up
actually the bank of England I think
raised them too slowly and hindsight's
an easy thing
um but yeah there's no question there
was a massive crisis short-term crisis
That Was Then stabilized but and that
was their own fault without question
absolutely and and we know that because
that's where all the professionals point
to and secondly of course we also know
that on the first day that Mr kwartam
was in office he was offered the
opportunity to consider the obr's
independent review an independent
assessment and he refused to do well if
you actually I don't know whether you
read Liz truss's article so she wrote it
was in I think it's just that in her
Sunday Telegraph yeah so Liz trust her
coming out from the wherever she's been
hiding wrote a long defense an
explanation of of what they did and she
addressed that point specifically about
the obr she said that it would not it
would have been incredibly unusual for
them to have given an assessment on what
was a an Emergency statement and that
that in itself would have been semi
meaningless I mean I'm paraphrasing here
because they because of the way their
modeling works so there was a rationale
for not doing that but look the reality
is she accepts that they didn't
communicate this well they didn't
prepare the ground for it I thought it
was quite interesting Alison Woody had
to say on on the culture wars and you
know the resignation of Nicholas
sturgeon being the first example of you
know the extreme woke agenda really
hitting the buffers yes and that's been
a great Victory actually for the
conservative government a rare Victory
actually I mean the Rishi sunak
um invoking I think it's article 35 of
the Scotland act to stop this thing in
its tracks I mean actually someone was
joking this week that Nicholas sturgeon
may have gone but she could be back as
Nicholas sturgeon
but poor Nicola no if you think about it
that that absolutely appalling thing
that she tried to push through we did
have as quasi quateng was saying we had
this double rapist
um who halfway through his trial decided
that he was going to be called Isla who
would have been allowed to go to a
woman's prison um yeah and I think this
is a very strong issue issue for the
Tories but I think just just coming back
quickly to the economic thing I think
classic protein was being quite loyal to
Liz trust because I understand there
were certain things in the package that
he didn't want lowering the top rate of
tax from 45 to 40. he didn't think they
should do it all at once and that's
where it came on stuck Richard don't you
think I think so but Paula do you also
think that I also pushed him quite hard
about the bank of England about some of
the people around him and I think he was
very he was very Coy but I suspect or
Katie
yes yeah I mean the problem is he was
let down by a lot of people because it
seems that they didn't include the right
people in terms of those important
decisions that maybe everybody was
caught off guard I don't know look we
want to talk about Dominic rods don't we
because I know Alison you feel very
strongly about the minister who's under
a lot of pressure over a number of
bullying allegations
um I know Dominic Robb I've never
detected that side to his personality
but then again I don't work for him for
me the thing that concerns me is a
pattern of behavior emerging whereby
unelected unaccountable Anonymous civil
servants yes are able to challenge a
democratically elected and appointed
politician running a department because
they find them a little bit too tough
yes I mean I think there are I think
there are eight formal complaints of
bullying against in which Dominic Robb
denies uh it's now under investigation
by KC and what struck me was I mean you
shouldn't laugh because bullying proper
bullying is very very serious and if
you've ever experienced it it's
completely horrible but some of the
leaking the endless leaking I mean some
of the complaints are just far circles
become faster with the hard stairs and I
think there's hard Clippers Angela
Rayner accused him of throwing throwing
a tomato or something
salad and let's see if we can listen to
that clip
the Prime Minister defends his Deputy
whose Behavior has been described as
abrasive controlling and demeaning with
junior staff Mr Speaker two scared to
even enter his office and that's without
mentioning the flying Tomatoes the
Deputy Prime Minister knows his behavior
is unacceptable so what's he still doing
here
prime minister Mr Speaker I'm here and
happy to address any specific point she
wishes to make that well that never
happened uh she says from a sedentary
position and I will thoroughly rebut and
refute any of the claims that be made
I'm I'm now regretting that we didn't
bring some tomatoes
cherry tomatoes
he just throw them he
'd be dangerous
because it's on wouldn't it be oh look
Paula you're probably a bit more
sympathetic you know you're to the to
the those who are supposedly the victims
of this tough Behavior well I think we
have to be careful of course we do
because there are four more complaints
that have been raised against Dominic
Robb what I don't understand is that
when you are a manager and you are aware
that allegations have been made against
you because I noticed that Rishi sunak
is pointing out that he was never aware
of any informal
um never aware of any formal allegations
being made only since recently this
jumping around about informal formal
come on we've all worked in an office if
somebody's saying something about you
you know about it and what I'm concerned
about is as a manager if you are hearing
People Say Something challenge it deal
with it we can always rely on Paula to
see the softness the right side next
right tonight millions are risking
prosecution by buying cannabis illegally
to ease medical symptoms so should
politicians look at relaxing the law on
using weed for medicinal purposes that
debate is coming up next
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no with the people's Channel no we're
gonna use every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
thank you foreign
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
well coming up on the talk Nicola
Bully's family hit out at speculation
and rumors that they say distracting
from the search for the missing mum and
King Charles faces anti-monarchy
protesters on his latest Royal Walkabout
in Milton Keynes and is being
middle-aged a thing of the past well
this 50 year old says so that's all at
nine o'clock
thank you
and welcome back to Piers Morgan
uncensored well should we take another
look at relaxing the law on cannabis for
medicinal use it's currently a Class B
drug which means you risk five years in
prison or an unlimited fine if you're
caught in possession of it and yet since
November 2018
specialist NHS doctors have actually
been allowed to prescribe cannabis for
conditions like severe epilepsy and
multiple sclerosis and the UK also has
23 private medical cannabis clinics
which can actually prescribe it for a
far wider set of conditions it comes
either as an oil in a capsule or even it
can be Vaped but new figures suggest
that last year nearly 2 million people
got hold of cannabis illegally to
alleviate pain and medical symptoms so
just the law need a rethink or would it
create a two-tier system where the rich
could access medicinal cannabis and the
less well-off couldn't well joining us
now in the studio is Professor Mike
Barnes chair of the Cannabis Industry
Council and a former consultant
neurologist and former conservative
cabinet minister Ann Whitaker well
Richard this is one of your favorite
topics I'm going to let you lead on I
think it's I think it's so important
that we try and get this right I think
Mike there are some 71 countries that in
various ways have legalized cannabis to
a degree that's right I think we are if
not I think we're the largest grower and
exporter of cannabis for medicinal
purposes
and yet yes it's really tough to be able
to use it if you're suffering pain and
symptoms here in the UK yes it's anomaly
isn't it that we're the largest exporter
of cannabis in the world yet all that is
grown in this country is exported and
all this Supply in this country is
imported which is a crazy situation it's
very difficult to get all by four
prescriptions are private there's now
about 25 000 people who've been
prescribed privately in the UK which is
progress
when as you say you compare that to
nearly 2 million you'll take it every
day for medical purposes we're not
talking about recreational use here then
that's a tiny from a health perspective
two million people getting it illicitly
yeah two million in Britain yes wow I
mean that is it's extraordinary where do
those figures come from it was a yougov
poll right uh it was about 1.4 million
pre-covered it's growing up it's
actually 1.8 million postcode which does
also show probably an impact of covid or
an impact of the publicity surrounding
the legality of cannabis now people
realize they can't get it so what do
they do they go to the illicit Market uh
to get it installed I mean I was going
to ask you about
um how what are the kind of figures
involved economically I mean I was
guessing that actually they weren't huge
talk about the import export ludicrous
situation yeah and what's this Market
worth for medicinal purposes well the
patients who have to be private spend
about an average of 500 pounds a month
six thousand miles that's an awful lot
of money that's excludes whatever 90
plus the population which is disgraceful
really considering it is legal the NHS
can prescribe it we don't need to change
the law
um so it's it's odd and they're Faith
they're vaping it all generally oils or
um most of the prescriptions are for oil
and vape about 50 50. so what would you
like to see happen
there I'd like to see it commonly NHS
and make that happen I think we need to
do two main things one is to allow GPS
to prescribe to initiate prescription at
the moment they can't it's Hospital
doctors only which I think is silly and
wrong and secondly is the guidelines are
rather restrictive uh nice reduced
guidelines were rather anti-countable
let's let's bring in Anne widicum onto
this debate and good evening thanks for
being with us on this look if people
people are suffering pain and cannabis
is a way of of relieving that suffering
there's nothing wrong with that is Iran
that's quite a lot of drugs if you well
know that you
that you've made because you wouldn't
they have to be prescribed they have to
be prescribed after Catholic examination
etc etc and at the moment cannabis is
one of those drugs there was a time when
it wasn't prescribed at all uh but it
can now be prescribed um and I mean an
obvious example you can't just go and
get morphine you know it's it's got to
be prescribed
um and there's no good reason I can see
uh why you shouldn't be able just to go
and get cannabis and one of the things
that worries me about it is
um you know we're accepting this figure
of 2 million which has been extracted
from a bowl uh but I wouldn't be at all
surprised uh if people were using it
rapidly creationally yeah but saying
that they were using it for medicinal
purposes there's got to be some control
I mean I have never been in favor as
well you know Richard of legalizing the
Cannabis because I think it will drive
all the profits of the drug Barons and
the hard drugs because we know a certain
percentage goes through the Gateway into
hard drugs so I've never been in favor
of its legalization I have always said
if the government's medical advisors
tell them that it should be prescribed
for medicinal purposes that was
something completely different and that
indeed has happened
I mean Anne makes a good point there
doesn't she Professor that that of I
don't really believe this two million
figure that are really using it for
medicinal purposes isn't this just a
kind of cover for you know trying to
have a bit of a I don't think so if you
look at other countries where it has
become much more readily available the
the rough indication about two to three
percent of the population that's
worldwide looking at the countries that
have collected those statistics you move
that to the UK and it's 1.5 to 2 million
now clearly As I understood there's a
bit of an overlap obviously there are
some people who have pain and they enjoy
the relaxation that a recreational Hive
the pain might just be a little headache
or something well I don't I think you're
underestimating I think there's a
there's a lot of genuine people let's
call it a little less than two million
if you like because of that overlap area
but there's at least 1.5 million people
a worldwide experience that really do
suffer chronic long-term conditions who
would be helped by cannabis and what is
the risk Mike of people getting addicted
to these prescriptions in the way that
people can get addicted to many other
drugs that are prescribed and that's
clearly a big concern that people like
Anne may have it's virtually not a
concern if it's prescribed properly
medically because a doctor who knows
what the obvious one is psychosis or
schizophrenia or some heart conditions
um you take those out they're not safe
to be prescribed generally speaking but
they they prescribe it safely they
prescribe it uh modestly but we're not
talking about the levels you get in in
recreational Cannabis by any means right
okay and without confusing things the
THC is the component that gets people
High that has medical value so it
wouldn't really work 3D sorry to
interrupt let you finish but but if it's
low level
um would it work for people who are
depressed you know mood it does okay
about a third of the prescriptions are
for those with anxiety particularly
right but other related conditions such
as depression PTSD but does it then not
affect their ability to actually get on
with doing a job no it doesn't if it's
prescribed properly there are there are
cannabis varieties that can sedate
people they want to help them sleep but
there's others that alert them so they
can go about their day and perfectly
normally and if you accept that
carefully prescribed the can be benefits
where are you and on the sort of the
balance between private clinics where
there seem to be only 23 at the moment
which clearly is a drop in the ocean and
the NHS is this something the NHS should
be doing
well of course the NHS is already as
we've heard in your introduction Channel
already uh prescribed I need a lot of
convince him frankly that doctors who
are very heavily pressured at the moment
um are going to uh be able to prescribe
each individual very carefully we
already know there's no big secret we
already know that they over prescribe
antibiotics because of patient pressure
we know that
um we know the dangers of endless repeat
conscriptions we know all of that the
idea that this is somehow going to be
different it isn't and so I think we
need to be mighty mighty careful I'm
glad that the NHS and prescribe where
it's necessary
um but it must be very heavily
controlled and it is at the moment and
it won't be if we just open it up to GPS
and how worried would you be Anne about
people on medical prescriptions getting
addicted to it
can be addicted
or more worried about you know the
gateway to the harder drugs which have
any seriously addicted
um so that's a concern but it's not my
major concern my major concern is
control over the prescribing which I
just don't believe uh would accept such
her own cabinets for antibiotics you
know that's what happens
oh why not just go for the whole
relaxation completely I mean what about
recreational use perhaps you're more
relaxed about that too no I think that's
that's a different agenda it's a
perfectly valid socio-political debate
but I don't want to talk about that
because that would I think detract from
getting the medical prescription right
we need to get the medical prescription
right I think if you open it up to
everybody people will go down to their
local Shop pharmacy get the Cannabis
without that supervision without knowing
what to take and how to take it so I
think it's really important to get some
medical control over the system so I I
would rather get the medical thing right
and then we can have a separate National
debate on recreational use I mean that's
what you what you want to do is just a
free-for-all isn't it no no I I think I
think we've got to look at it really
carefully I think there's a huge epoxy
about uh exporting it being a huge
exporter for medicinal purposes and not
properly being able to use it ourselves
I I am interested in Anne's point that
uh you know it's going to be hard for
doctors to get the prescriptions right
but I think we to be able to do that I
really worry that at the moment
basically if you're really suffering
pain and if it works for you but that's
only if you're rich and wealthy and you
can afford to get one of those things
you also want it to be free for all for
recreation I I think I think I think
we've got to have a proper grown-up
National debate about it and look at it
um but you shouldn't rush things but the
first bit is is where it's relieving
pain and clearly helping then then then
why prevent people why make it so
difficult and I think in the NHS it
really is clearly very very different
what Ann said was it was Prescott an NHS
that's four prescriptions and you know
four yeah I mean that's nothing I find
it weird that you're so kind of
passionate about this issue because
you've never even tried it have you no I
haven't but that I mean you know I'd
have to try something to to you don't
have to try something you always have a
view I think you do actually I mean I've
got your own experiences I know I have I
mean I I've tried it I tried it in
Seattle which where it's legal by the
way
um and I had a really bad experience I
had far too much it did not go well I
had a you know one of these jelly things
and I thought I'll have half and nothing
happened at all so I thought I'd have a
bit more and then a bit more and then
boy boom you know this was not good and
that has actually affected my my view on
this I think it's very very difficult to
to control okay but anyway properly
prescribed you wouldn't have had that
experience no I don't think I'm not
going to try that again you were a bit
too bullish I think I think I probably
was well look thank you very much uh
Professor for coming in and thank you
Anne and that is it from us peers is
going to be back from his from uh live
from New York City next week from Monday
and whatever you're up to make sure it's
uncensored good night good night
foreign
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no we're
gonna use uh every little helps for
God's sake is nothing original anymore
it's finger licking Goods I'm loving it
look let's be honest we don't have any
fancy speech writers here but we do and
I promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it well
that one too
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talktv